[Musik]
>> SALLY: Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein absolutes
Basic-Grundrezept.
Es gibt French Toast
oder auch Arme Ritter genannt.
Warum heißen die Arme Ritter?
Denn es ist wirklich so ein Armeleuteessen.
Man braucht im Prinzip nur altes Toastbrot
oder altes Brot,
– beziehungsweise, wenn man eben altes Brot hat,
kann man es super aufpimpen –
ein paar Eier, ein bisschen Milch
und macht sich richtig lecker French Toast daraus.
Das Ganze kann man entweder süß essen,
so, wie ich es gerne esse,
oder eben auch herzhaft.
Also man muss nicht zwingend French Toast
oder Arme Ritter süß verspeisen.
Ich zeige euch jetzt erst mal die klassische Variante
und dann noch die vegane Variante.
Die ist nämlich auch supereinfach.
Für die klassische Variante nehme ich
zwei Eier,
140 Gramm Milch,
etwas Vanilleextrakt und eine Prise Zimt,
sechs Scheiben Toastbrot.
Ich habe jetzt hier Vollkorntoast.
Zum Ausbacken etwas Butter.
Und ich serviere es hier gleich
mit Himbeeren, Erdnussbutter und Kakaonibs.
Also, wie ihr unschwer erkennen könnt,
mache ich jetzt natürlich die süße Variante.
Wenn ihr es herzhaft macht,
würde ich einfach sagen, Vanilleextrakt und Zimt weglassen,
eine Prise Salz vielleicht dazu
oder einfach neutral lassen.
So kann man nämlich am Frühstückstisch entscheiden,
ob süß oder herzhaft.
So.
Also im Prinzip
kann man es gar kein Rezept nennen.
Denn das ist wirklich ganz schnell gemacht.
Jetzt verquirle ich hier die Eier mit der Milch.
Also, zack, hier rein.
Mein Vanilleextrakt neigt sich dem Ende zu.
Aber es reicht noch für die zwei Sachen.
Für die reicht es noch.
Und ich zeige euch gleich,
wie ihr hier alle Reste noch raus bekommt. Okay?
So. Während das hier runtertropft,
gebe ich schon mal
– ups –
Zimt dazu.
Was davon übrig ist.
Ja, komm. Eine Prise hier.
Zack, zack, zack.
Drei Tage später...
Vier Tage später...
Vier Jahre später...
Das Ganze jetzt kurz verrühren.
Wiu-wiu-wiu!
Ich habe so Hunger!
Deswegen mache ich jetzt einfach ganz schnell.
Wir hatten vorher nämlich nur
so einen Erdbeer-Shake,
so Resteverwertung an Früchten.
So.
Und normalerweise sagt man jetzt,
von beiden Seiten eintauchen und so weiter.
Ich mache es meist einfach ganz pragmatisch,
ganz easy.
Ich übergieße sie.
Und dann habt ihr das Gleiche in weniger Zeit.
Ich möchte jetzt Vanilleextrakt auch überall dran haben,
diese Vanillekörnchen.
Jetzt einfach hier schauen
und so ein bisschen drin wenden.
Und daher ist auch so ein bisschen altes Brot ganz gut,
weil es wirklich dann die Flüssigkeit perfekt aufsaugt.
Und, wenn ihr merkt,
hey, da passt noch ein bisschen Brot dazu,
legt es einfach rein.
Das heißt, verbraucht ruhig die komplette Flüssigkeit.
Schade wäre wirklich, wenn was übrig bleibt.
So.
Kommt halt echt so ein bisschen auch
auf die Feuchtigkeit des Brotes an.
Hier noch.
Und dann lasse ich das jetzt hier einfach kurz ziehen
und kann schon mal die Butter schmelzen.
Ich nehme jetzt hier einfach meinen eckigen Gusseisenbräter,
weil ich, glaube ich, alle sechs mit rein kriege.
Ihr könnt aber auch einfach
eine teflonbeschichtete Pfanne nehmen,
also einfach eine Antihaftpfanne.
Bei Antihaftpfannen ist es so,
da könnt ihr wirklich mit weniger Butter auskommen.
Aber ich muss dazusagen,
Butter gibt den Armen Rittern und dem French Toast
einfach den perfekten Geschmack!
Hier habe ich ja keine Beschichtung.
Das heißt, hier brauche ich ein bisschen mehr Fett,
aber bin gleichzeitig fertig.
Jetzt ist wichtig, bei mittelhoher Hitze anbraten,
damit es einfach nicht verbrennt von außen.
Denn es soll ja auch innen gut durchbacken.
Also wirklich nur mittelhoch.
Ich mache das jetzt hier so,
gebe, wie gesagt, die Butter rein.
Und, weil ich weiß, ich habe hier keine Beschichtung,
ein bisschen mehr Butter.
Ich mag Butter.
>> SAMIRA: Mama?
>> SALLY: Hm?
>> SAMIRA: Wenn du so machst,
– guck –
dann hast du kleine Grübchen.
>> SALLY: Hm.
Ich dachte immer als Kind,
dass ich Grübchen habe,
weil das Fleisch hier nicht ausgereicht hat im Gesicht.
Ja.
Ein Loch.
Zwei.
[Musik]
Wenn, dann alles.
Ich kontrolliere die Hitze jetzt hier
einfach mit dem PerfectFry-Sensor.
Das heißt, ich habe den jetzt auf Stufe 1.
Das heißt für mich,
[Pieptöne]
der Bräter
– jetzt ist es warm.
Der Bräter behält einfach die ganze Zeit die Hitze
und ich muss nicht schauen.
Wenn ihr das nicht habt, gar nicht schlimm.
Ich sage es nur immer dazu,
weil viele jetzt auch mittlerweile die Geräte haben
und einfach immer wieder fragen:
"Wann benutzt du den Sensor?
Wann nimmst du Backsensor?"
Also hier benutze ich es jetzt.
Wie gesagt, Stufe 1.
Oder ansonsten ganz einfach bei niedriger Temperatur.
Jetzt lege ich die rein
und backe sie dann für etwa zwei bis drei Minuten
von jeder Seite aus,
bis sie schön goldbraun sind.
[Musik]
Und den Rest im Teller
einfach so noch mal darüber verteilen
ganz gleichmäßig.
Gerade so auf denen, die oben lagen.
Die unten, die sind nämlich richtig schön nass.
Hach, perfekt!
O Gott! Ich freue mich da schon
echt ewig darauf!
Endlich!
So.
Ausbacken und gleich servieren.
[Musik]
Und ich habe jetzt hier einfach PerfectFry Stufe 4 gewählt.
So kann ich die French Toast, die Armen Ritter,
wirklich perfekt goldbraun ausbacken
und die Temperatur bleibt immer schön gleich.
Ihr müsst einfach mal gucken.
Tastet euch heran.
Je nachdem, was für Kochgeschirr ihr auch habt,
erst mal lieber niedriger starten,
Stufe 1, 2, 3.
Und wenn ihr merkt, okay, es kann noch brauner werden,
dann nehmt ihr einfach Stufe 4.
[Musik]
Ja.
Und jetzt im Prinzip am besten
direkt auf einen Teller und servieren.
Ich werde jetzt aber gleich noch die veganen machen.
Aber ich zeige euch, wie ich diese hier serviere.
Daher nehme ich die jetzt kurz raus.
Und, damit sie jetzt nicht einfach übereinander gestapelt
nass werden und die Knusprigkeit verlieren,
setzte ich die jetzt hierhin.
Hach!
Uns läuft hier so das Wasser im Mund zusammen.
Josh, bei dir auch?
>> JOSH: Ja.
>> SALLY: Kamera noch okay?
>> JOSH: Es geht. Ich wackle schon ein bisschen.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Ich schalte das mal hier kurz aus.
Oh!
Das ist echt so megalecker!
Okay.
Achtung!
Jetzt machen wir das so.
Ihr könnt ihn natürlich servieren, wie ihr möchtet.
Aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal meinen Vorschlag.
Ich glaube, ich darf euch gar nicht sagen,
wie viele davon ich essen kann.
Ach, ich glaube, ich mache einen höheren Berg sogar.
Wisst ihr, ich muss jetzt gerade das Foto anrichten
– also ich muss gerade so im Foto denken.
Sally, denke
wie ein Food-Fotograf!
Oh yes!
Ja.
Ja. Ja.
Ich bin halt Team Erdnussbutter.
Nur so, so darüber schmelzen.
Hm.
Josh, bist du auch Team Erdnussbutter?
>> JOSH: Mh.
Ich muss sagen, Zimt und Zucker
bin ich da absoluter Fan davon.
>> SALLY: Dann Himbeeren.
Zimtzucker ginge.
Also eigentlich Zimtzucker drauf
und ihr seid perfekt bedient.
Bin ich auch,
bin ich auch Fan.
Also ich bin eigentlich Fan von allem,
alles mit,
ja, alles.
Und jetzt noch so Kakaonibs.
Kakaonibs ist ja praktisch
die natürlichste Form der Schokolade.
Denn es ist einfach
gebrochene Kakaobohne.
Und das gefällt mir jetzt so schon ganz gut.
Und jetzt ein bisschen süßen Schnee.
Das ist praktisch der Puderzucker, der nicht schmilzt.
Daaa!
French Toast!
Zack!
[Musik]
Ich sehe schon, wir kommen nicht zur veganen Variante,
bevor wir nicht probiert haben.
Also, Josh, ich muss jetzt dich probieren lassen. Okay?
Schwupp.
>> JOSH: Ich habe die Aufnahmen auf Band.
>> SALLY: Schwupp.
Guck mal. So sieht es auch schön aus, nicht?
Und ich habe die Erdnussbutter einfach ein bisschen erwärmt.
So fließt sie darüber.
Und ich finde, man muss jetzt schon
viele Himbeeren dazu essen.
Denn
der French Toast ist ja praktisch nicht süß.
Der ist ja so
recht neutral.
Die Kakaonibs für den Crunch.
Und süßer Schnee.
Ja.
Okay. Ich schneide es dir kurz an.
Ich gebe dir dann so ein Stück.
Ich schneide das jetzt mit dem Pizzarad an.
So.
Lieber Josh,
bitte.
>> JOSH: Danke schön.
>> SALLY: Liebe Sally,
das ist für deinen Einsatz.
Hm!
>> JOSH: Okay, überzeugt.
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> JOSH: Absolut überzeugt.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Wir naschen das jetzt hier noch auf.
Und dann gibt es Version zwei.
[Musik]
Es ist so.
Die einfachsten Sachen machen dich einfach so glücklich.
Wir sind gerade wie auf Wolke sieben.
Jetzt zeige ich euch die vegane Version.
Da nehme ich praktisch nur Pflanzenmilch dafür
und Bananen als Eierersatz.
Also habe ich jetzt hier
200 Gramm vegane Pflanzenmilch,
zwei Bananen,
– da brauche ich 250 Gramm –
wieder Vanilleextrakt und Zimt,
die sechs Toastscheiben,
etwas vegane Butter zum Ausbacken.
Und die serviere ich jetzt mit
Blaubeeren,
Physalis,
süßem Schnee
und Schokoladencreme.
Ich muss jetzt gesehen,
die Schokoladencreme ist jetzt nicht vegan.
Das ist eine Nougatcreme.
Aber da konnte ich dem Josh nicht widerstehen.
Wir haben auch vegane Schokoladencreme da
beziehungsweise ich mache sie sogar selber gerne,
selbstgemachte Nuss-Nougat-Creme.
Aber, da jetzt kein Veganer probiert...
Ich meine, wenn ihr vegan seid,
dann nehmt ihr einfach vegane Schokocreme.
Wir nehmen jetzt die.
So. Ist jetzt halt so bestimmt.
Ist so.
Aha.
Haben wir uns das stibitzt?
Sarah ist ein French-Toast-Dieb!
Genau. Was ich jetzt machen werde,
ich messe ganz kurz die Banane ab.
Die Bananen dürfen auch wirklich schon megareif sein.
Und jetzt hier 250 Gramm.
Ui!
Je reifer...
Ich bin schon ganz durcheinander!
Alle so: "Hunger! Hunger! Mach schnell!"
Je reifer die Banane, umso süßer natürlich.
Ich brauche sogar noch ein bisschen.
Habe ich nicht?
Egal.
>> JOSH: Da vorne?
>> SALLY: Nee. Egal.
Ich habe jetzt keine Banane mehr.
Aber ist egal.
Genau, jetzt noch den Trick mit dem Vanilleextrakt.
Da bleibt ja immer gern so ein Rest übrig.
Das hätte ich jetzt natürlich vor der Banane machen müssen.
Egal.
Ich gebe hier einfach Milch rein.
Ich gebe zu, manchmal mache ich das auch
für den morgendlichen Kaffee.
Wenn ich sehe so, oh, Vanilleextrakt ist leer,
dann spüle ich es halt kurz mit der Milch aus,
gebe es in den Kaffee rein.
Jetzt einfach schütteln.
Und – guckt – dann löst sich nämlich schön alles
und ihr habt wirklich
jedes kleine Fitzelchen an Vanilleextrakt noch verwertet.
Das kommt hier dazu.
Das sieht voll schwarz aus jetzt.
Ihr könnt das auch mit Rum zum Beispiel machen.
Dann könnt ihr es sogar in der Flasche lassen,
solltet es dann nur nicht vertauschen
mit eurem anderen Vanilleextrakt,
was nämlich nicht alkoholisch ist.
So.
Zimt rein.
Und jetzt kurz pürieren.
Ihr könnt natürlich auch die Bananen einfach
mit der Gabel zerdrücken.
Aber so werden sie einfach etwas feiner.
[Musik]
Ich muss sagen, 200 Gramm Banane
hat jetzt auch super ausgereicht.
Hier mache ich es jetzt aber so,
ich übergieße sie tatsächlich erst mal einzeln.
Denn diese Milch ist einfach etwas dickflüssiger.
O Gott! Das sieht so schon lecker aus!
[Musik]
In der Zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal
die Butter wieder schmelzen
und euren Gusseisenbräter
oder eben auch eure Pfanne einfach erhitzen.
Und jetzt wieder einfach ausbacken.
Ich glaube tatsächlich, da kann ich mehrere daraus machen.
Denn die Flüssigkeit ist viel mehr,
reicht mehr als nur für sechs Portionen.
[Musik]
Anrichten!
Also, was ich sagen muss zum einen,
ich habe natürlich jetzt mehr Toasts rausbekommen.
Und zum anderen brauchen sie etwas länger im Ausbacken.
Denn Ei stockt natürlich schneller,
als jetzt hier die Milch mit der Banane
praktisch verdampft und durchbackt.
Aber ich muss sagen,
trotzdem die Oberfläche schön knusprig.
Ich türme das jetzt wieder so.
Ich glaube, ich mache hier tatsächlich fünf
Aber ich nehme ein goldenes noch drauf.
Haha.
Und hier habe ich jetzt die Schokocreme erwärmt.
Yummy, yummy, yummy
in my tummy
gleich!
Hach!
Ich kann mir schon
die Kombination Schoko, Banane vorstellen.
Du auch?
>> JOSH: Ja.
Also ich muss ja zurücknehmen,
dass ich im Team Zimt und Zucker bin.
Ich bin auf jeden Fall Nougat-Banane.
>> SALLY: Vor allem Zartbitter-Nougat.
Boah!
So Bananenscheiben wären jetzt auch gut.
Aber die werden halt schnell braun.
Das muss man wissen.
O Gott!
Und diese Physalis!
Und wie gut passt die hier bitte dazu?
Bitte schön.
[Musik]
Vegan!
Das bekommt Sarah zum Fotografieren.
Josh, wir richten uns schnell unseren Teller an,
während die anderen noch ausbacken.
Das ist wie so ein Ehepärchenteller, nicht?
Also ich muss sagen,
die Fotos
– also den Teller habe ich jetzt so angerichtet für die Fotos.
Sieht halt hammermäßig aus!
Wenn wir jetzt am Frühstückstisch sitzen
oder am Mittagstisch
oder Abendtisch,
egal, wann auch immer,
dann gibt es natürlich die French Toasts auf einem Teller,
jeder nimmt sich einen runter, belegt ihn.
Weil man will ja auch so viel Belag wie möglich
auf dem einen haben.
Ist halt so.
Ich glaube, ich bin der einzige Mensch,
der das mit dem Pizzarad macht.
Vegan!
Veganer French Toast!
Piuh!
Gönnt euch.
Di-dim, di-dim, di-dim,
di-dim, di-dim.
[Musik]
Dim, dim, dim, dim,
düüt.
>> JOSH: Oh, wie süß!
>> SALLY: O mein Gott!
Ich glaube,
ich finde tatsächlich die Banane-French-Toast-Variante
hundertmillionenmal besser
als die Ei-Variante.
>> JOSH: Geschmacksexplosion!
>> SALLY: Richtige Geschmacksexplosion!
Geschmacksexplosion!
O mein Gott!
Probiert auf jeden Fall beide Varianten aus.
Schreibt mir, was euch am besten schmeckt.
Also ich würde sagen, wir stimmen ab
zwischen French Toast mit Zimtzucker,
French Toast fruchtig,
French...
Ach, egal.
Stimmt einfach ab.
Schreibt es einfach in die Kommentare.
Weil vielleicht habt ihr ja noch bessere Vorschläge,
andere Vorschläge,
herzhafte Vorschläge.
Und wir können mal French Toast Deluxe machen,
wenn ihr möchtet.
Schreibt es gerne in die Kommentare.
Und dann sehen wir uns wieder beim nächsten Mal.
Die Rezepte gibt es natürlich auf sallys-blog.de,
in meiner kostenlosen App,
wo ihr sie hoch- und runterrechnen könnt
je nachdem, wie groß die Portion bei euch sein soll.
Also bis bald!
Tschüss!
[Musik]